يبدو ان اثار عقارب ارستمول المستخدم للحد
من الالم تمتد الى العمليات النفسيه
المختلفه الذي يسبب انخفاض التعاطف وحتى
اضعاف الوظائف المعرفيه بحسب الدراسات
فيما وجدت دراسه حديثه ان الاستخدام طويل
الاماكن المسكن باراسيتا مول يزيد من
احتماليه الاصابه بامراض القلب والسكته
الدماغيه لدى مرضى ارتفاع ضغط الدم لنحو
20% ونبهه دراسه البريطانيه الى ان نتناول
الفرس ستمر المسكنه في منتصف فتره الحمل
يعرض المواليد لخطر فرط النشاط ومشاكل
انتباه والسلوكيات الصعبه الاخرى بين
السنه سته اشهر والاحد عشره عاما وخرج
الدراسه من جامعه
الى الصعوبات والمشاكل في النطق عند
الفتيات اللواتي تناولت امهاتهم تلك
الحبوب المسكنه اثناء الحمل